[Music]
last night RuPaul made her Surry
becoming the first drag queen to host
Saturday Night Live in the show's
45-year history and as expected rue was
amazing and his opening monologue
RuPaul took the time to do what he does
best inspire don't take life too
seriously I mean there are things I take
seriously I take kindness seriously I
take love seriously but all the rest
baby just have fun and if you follow
your heart and dare to be different and
use all the colors in the crayon box
who knows where you'll end up if you're
lucky you just might find yourself
hosting Saturday night I love that
message last night there were so many
hilarious sketches I thought it would be
fun to take a look at some of the best
of the night now these are just my
opinion starting things off my absolute
favorite sketch of last night was one
called the library now I'll show you how
to read then you try what's your name
her name is Caitlin can she read she's
starting to yeah Oh Kaitlin sweetie I
bet you have plenty of washed up basic
little friends that you cannot wait to
read the bill and from there RuPaul read
some of our favorite childhood books to
filth
Eloise by Kay Thompson mm-hmm Oh Eloise
you need to call the front desk and get
a hot oil treatment for that room on
your hand
Victoria's Secret call they want they
wallpaper back
and what is she do it pop in a fart miss
Madeline I have bad news child the
Eiffel Tower is not in the woods France
right like they've been to Paris
you ain't never been there girl no doubt
that was a fan favorite of the night
another Santos sketch was the return of
Chad yes that's right Pete Davidson and
RuPaul together in a sketch called Chad
Andrew Paul where Roo is looking for the
new face of drag and finds something
special in Chad everyone take five leave
me with the future of drag okay um I
guess for taking five mmm
that face those cheekbones
these eyes there's something dynamic
about you boy okay have you ever done
tried no just weed and pills there's a
queen inside of you all she needs is a
crowd
may I okay oh wow that is definitely
your color Chad now pop your lips like
you're about to kiss
[Music]
Oh shad darling I'm a married man
you're a man did you not know that no
tens across the board now let me see you
[ __ ] that Wow
okay
I love chat Pete looks pretty good in
drag
right he actually looks a little bit
like drag race star Morgan McMichaels
now no shade is meant by that at all
they are both beautiful in drag
my third favorite sketch of the night
was called cheque splitting which had
RuPaul and Cecily strong as two women
who try to stand up for a co-worker who
reluctantly agrees to splitting a
restaurant bill evenly because she
didn't have any why the rest of us we're
gonna split it is that okay with
everyone oh well I didn't have wine yeah
it's just easier if you're okay with
that well Candace I think you ought to
ask yourself if you're a supervisor or a
taker of advantages of people I'm sorry
I'm not following well let me draw a map
for your thoughts
there you are strong-arming a woman to
pay for wine that she did not invite and
furthermost
expect her to quietly sit and roll over
like a prostitute from the amsterdam
district I think not this woman goes
home to nothing and nothing empty bed
empty head and all your creditors want
to empty her purse as well
she went to Sephora on her lunch break
to get our lashes put on top of her own
eyelashes pumping beyond all reason that
maybe someone would become a true friend
she has none seriously guys I will pay
the whole bill it's no big deal
Oh shall we all applaud Queen Candace
the queen of kindness and generosity
we've all been there now one low moment
of the night was the sketch pulled New
York Show with RuPaul
Aidy Bryant and Kate McKinnon feature
this sketch should have been a
no-brainer with the cast of those three
however
and it looked like they were having fun
on the cable-access sketch but it just
didn't bring the laughs I was also
hoping to see Justin Bieber in a skit
especially after we saw how good of a
beaver impression RuPaul could do on The
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon the
other night there has to have been
something there and here's one that you
didn't see as it was cut for time I hate
when that happens a sketch with RuPaul
and Bo and yang it was completely random
it's awesome check it out on SNL's
YouTube it really was a great night but
I did feel they did miss an opportunity
with something it would have been
amazing to have eight SNL cast members
recreate snatch game they already all do
so many amazing impressions proof of
that is Chloe fireman who killed these
impressions during Weekend Update ahead
of tonight's Academy Awards Renee
Zellweger broke from the form with some
backseat acting
[Laughter]
incredible right I was so glad to see
Chloe shine last night love
SNL so how do you think RuPaul did as
host what was your own personal favorite
sketch of the night did you have any
great sketch ideas you would have liked
the scene on the show let me know in the
comments below oh hey there if you want
more LGBTQ news and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos